all right time to go to work boo boo do
is a you don't be afraid of yourself
Moses my buddy
good morning welcome to vlog number five
my god want me to take you I need you
all righty ready to go now where's your
sister chica mom I can take oh no we're
gonna go together we're not taking two
trips she's one take it go get her in
the car and I'll take you right now
pretty typical morning in our house so
Jaya tomorrow's Friday and then the day
after that is Saturday and you don't
have school on Saturday but it's not
summer break
there's so many things that I have to
get done because we're going to Europe
early next week I'm going to be out of
the country for like three weeks which
means I got a bank for podcasts and have
them totally done before I go so I can
just be present and enjoy my trip
without having a moment
but first things first all right I only
have a couple hours to get out for a
quick spin I'm not going to bring the
GoPro on this ride I want to just be
focused and present for the experience
but I'll report back when I'm done all
done just a couple hours mellow z2 all
right
time to go to work so I'm prepping for
this podcast this afternoon with the
Iceman wim HOF he's the guy who believes
in cold exposure and breath work as a
means of basically accessing your
autonomous nervous system and using that
as a vehicle to heal yourself to prevent
and reverse disease to do superhuman
feats to recover more quickly as an
athlete and basically just access innate
reservoirs of potential which is really
cool to me god it's cold
you could say that I think of the gold
as a noble force it's just helping me
it's training me it's bringing me back
to the inner nature the way it was meant
to be and this way I do not only enjoy
the gold I love to cool
so what I'm doing is I'm just trying to
wrap my head around how I want to
approach this conversation I'm doing
some due diligence and research making
some notes and just kind of ruminating
on how I want to navigate the
personality that is wim hof but I'm
looking forward to it and I only have a
little bit of time before I have to go
back home where we're doing the podcast
so got to make the most of it time to go
there's a bird stuck in our bedroom let
me help you probably stuck it doesn't
want me to touch him of course I blame
you here we go oh my guy he dude it's
gonna be okay
ready ready to go poor guy that's
probably the best thing that'll happen
to me all day today
such a simple message you know yeah and
nobody doesn't write yeah I listen to
Joe and chairman and
Rhonda you know I cover the same things
but you have a different way and
hopefully killing Shirley yes but my
knowledge comes from nature
you know nature and then it got through
science I don't understand why two years
ago two and half years ago I the
autonomic nervous system to be able to
be influenced by anybody it's big big
time because the influence there from is
so huge it needs to be in charted
there's a whole other maps are going to
be drawn a new way this is the beginning
it is so damn we die that we meet yes
how's it going I am rich I know I'm Gus
Creek jpgs and I'm gonna meet you too
welcome thanks for coming and a big fan
Karen will you
um let me get we're gonna get up
Gabrielle over here chilling out a
little bit you guys have fun
I prefer a total a true Patrick ready to
go yes let's rocket rocket yeah I'm
meeting all kinds of people did Red Bull
the top athletes AHA the extreme athlete
I'm gonna trade him yeah
you through the Red Bull performance yes
dang that's pretty cool this morning we
have talks with the Warner Brothers they
want to do with series oh wow yeah yeah
yeah bad you know yeah yeah and you were
just with a deemed Blaine this morning
ah that was yesterday yesterday and I
was trying to figure out your secrets
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's no illusion ha
ha ha difference right ha ha ha do it
we'll have a good time
Yeah right up peace Thanks oh yeah yeah
yeah cool cool good yeah yeah it's good
it was good good good I'm Jimmy some
water
ha ha but getting back into the
spirituality that's where he belongs
come on yogi ah coming from you
great thank you very much tomorrow be
there possibly hunting Akitas and the
surfer dude or Kelly Kelly Slater Slater
yes later yeah and Darren Ali yeah yeah
we're ready
right I know all those guys yeah cool
there it is great yeah we keep you
updated okay we're doing good work yeah
I'm taking a bite Bob in the Sun hey
guys Webber Paris meet you look at your
eyes you are like lit up oh thank you
Johnny sweet sunshine it's amazing place
here but they're doing this half hour in
wintertime yeah great how many years
does it take to become timeless we're
all warriors on the same path we fight
for life and we want to bring light
that's the Guru Guru is there the one
who brings light without the Guru there
is no knowledge but they contradict
themselves too because there is also the
attitude a guru that adept a guru inside
so I always said boom guru is a you
don't be afraid of yourself what a cool
afternoon to spend with such an
extraordinary guy wim really inspires me
and the work that he's doing with cold
exposure and breathing techniques is
nothing short of mind-blowing I mean
this is a guy who has climbed Everest in
his shorts without a shirt on
he has swum 66 meters underneath a meter
of ice in northern Finland both world
records what else has he done he ran a
half marathon within the Arctic Circle
barefoot in shorts without a shirt on
another world record I mean he's done
some pretty remarkable things and he
attributes all of it to the work that he
has done with cold and more specifically
to the breathing techniques that he
develop and if you ask him he'll tell
you he's nobody special that he can
teach this to other people and he's
demonstrated that he's proven it out
time and time again the whole experience
has left me thinking a lot about human
capability and I think my takeaway is
that we are all sitting on top of vast
reservoirs of unexplored human potential
because if wind could do what he's done
then what else are we capable of doing I
have to believe that there are
additional mental and physical
capabilities that have yet to be
explored and that's a very exciting
proposition David Goggin said it best
when we think were absolutely cooked
we're done we can't go any further we've
actually only tapped into about 40
percent of what we're truly capable of
whim is living breathing proof of that
proposition and then some so I just want
to leave you guys with that thought what
are you not tapping into that would
allow you to be a better human being to
grow spiritually mentally emotionally
and physically that's what we're here to
do we're here to grow and we're here to
serve how can i establish a better
trajectory to maximize my potential how
can i become a better servant what are
the things that you're not doing that
would allow you to grow spiritually
emotionally mentally and physically so
today's call to action is simple what is
one thing that you can change and
incorporate into your daily routine that
will allow you to grow figure that out
and put it to work